tueurs à gages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
C'est un garçon il avait 15 ans 15 16 ans
le petit garçon sautait vers
États-Unis et l'a attaqué avec des balles
ils ont jeté le travail du
mais ils l'ont fait parce que c'était sur le côté
mexicain
ce avec quoi ils se protègent tout le temps, c'est
qu'ils sont censés les attaquer
des pierres mais
C'est déjà inhumain parce qu'une personne
ne se suicide plus simplement parce que
qu'est-ce que tu veux oui non plus pour vouloir traverser
aux États Unis
[Musique]
C'est la cave où ils sont allés
abattu 58 hommes et 14 femmes
les immigrés sans papiers qui tentaient d'atteindre
Déclare les citoyens du Honduras
Le Brésil, le Salvador et l'Équateur étaient
intercepté par des membres du
organisation criminelle connue sous le nom
carrelage
[Musique]
Il s'élève d'un côté de l'est
Augmenter
[Musique]
beauté
Ravi de vous rencontrer, ravi. Quel est votre nom ?
Je viens du Mexique, au sud du sud
et tu seras nodal oui
Voyons ce qui se passe à Nogales
C'est bien, ni moi ni mes amis
Sébastien beaucoup
vous venez également du Mexique Honduras
Honduras
il fait chaud il fait chaud
Donc tu n'as pas de passeport
tu dois te cacher de tout et de tout le monde
Et qu'est-ce que tu as laissé à cette famille ?
frères et sœurs
Pour eux nous nous battons sur ce chemin
avec foi en Dieu que nous allons faire quelque chose
et sinon, nous y retournons et
Où as-tu dormi
prendre le train et monter à Nogales
nous restons tous ensemble
Ne t'éloigne pas de là-haut si tu
tu viens de glisser, alors ne lâche pas
des tragédies peuvent arriver
donc avec tes bras tu dois courir
donc avec le train, cours, cours, cours et toi
accélérez un peu et retrouvez votre équilibre
[Musique]
là, ils montent
L'autre
[Musique]
c'est encore le plan
pour ça
comme ça va se passer, oui, ça peut être fait rapidement
Eh bien, s'il l'attrape et vous grimpe, mais
Vous ne l'attraperez jamais à cette vitesse.
presque la majorité doit partir
courir sur le côté
exprès. Alors il le fait parce que
ils sont ici
Eh bien, excuse-moi alors
de nourriture ici autour des maisons, ok
ok, nous le serons, merci
[Musique]
Oh, qu'est-ce qui t'est arrivé
est avec un dormeur avant
qui séparait le train ici à la gare et
En arrivant ici, je suis allé à l'hôpital
Oh, bien sûr, ils t'ont cuisiné hier
Dimanche
et tu essaies d'aller vers le nord jusqu'à ce que
Noix
salut bien
[Musique]
Le Père Enrique est là
nous te remercions Seigneur pour cela
la nourriture que vous nous avez fournie
Nous vous demandons également les personnes qui
Ils les ont faits, demandons à tout le monde
nos biens
donnez du pain monsieur à ceux qui ont faim
et faim et soif de justice envers nous qui
nous avons du pain par le Christ notre Seigneur
au nom du père du fils du
Saint Esprit
[Musique]
cette première première partie peut
en recevoir un ou plusieurs, pas plusieurs
fois
et ils le font, ils le font beaucoup, ils mangent beaucoup
exactement tu lui as dit que parfois
les migrants nous ont pris, nous ont séparés
beaucoup peuvent être petits
je ne viens plus
ce qui se passe, ce n'est pas de la politique
laisse le train monter pour qu'il n'avance pas
mais l'état de l'état est présenté
mexicain
[Musique]
ou la police loin de les cuisiner
Eh bien, laissez-les prendre soin d'eux. Ce qui se passe, c'est que
profitant à plusieurs reprises du pouvoir
Eh bien, plusieurs fois, ils le maintiennent
que peut-il arriver aux migrants
quand ils viennent du sud jusqu'à ce qu'ils partent
au nord
adversités et si l'adversité est
prendre le train est le pire
de frapper depuis avoir été agressé
puisqu'ils ont été extorqués depuis
vos biens sont volés ou emportés
[Musique]
maintenant ils savent que tu dois arriver en retard
[Des rires]
La vérité
Nous marchons
[Musique]
d'où ont-ils parlé
Écoute, ils me disent que depuis
L'Amérique centrale parle de ce père et
moi dans tout le Mexique
le père et c'est pourquoi nous savons qu'ici
C'était bien, tout le monde s'en souvient déjà
quand ils reviennent
[Musique]
eh bien, j'ai apporté de l'eau pour le train banane
fromage fromage vitamines
et les pommes ok
[Musique]
eau de fruit
dans la tradition, c'est moche pour beaucoup
rien n'arrive à beaucoup de gens
quelque chose arrive aux gens ici mais à beaucoup
les gens ont de mauvaises choses qui leur arrivent, hein dans le
entraîner le train, rien ne se passe
trois fois moins je me suis évanoui et quand
Ils m'ont réveillé parce que je ne pouvais pas le supporter
les coups de pied dans les côtes qui
ils ont cédé et m'ont réveillé à nouveau
Je ne sais pas qui serait ce problème ici, n'est-ce pas ?
Je sais qui ce serait et mes oncles policiers
ou ils s'habillent en noir avec un chapeau
a également couvert le pistolet facial
Je ne pouvais pas voir parce que juste avec ça
Pouvez-vous regarder un peu cette oreille ?
C'était comme si gros et je l'ai apporté
battue ici, je me l'amène fracturée
Ils m'ont frappé fort mais au moins ils ne m'ont pas battu
Ils ont tué le patron parce qu'ils m'ont jeté
Ils ont dit regarde ce qu'ils me disent, regarde maintenant
oui, il dit pour un autre argent et ils m'ont poussé
C'est ainsi que j'ai expliqué le bon Non pour
s'il te plaît, ne m'écoute pas
Sebastian qui était l'un d'entre eux parce que j'étais
Je ne pouvais rien y faire
J'étais comme ça et un bon m'a attrapé d'ici et
une des jambes et ils m'ont fait comme ça et maintenant
oui tu vas savoir ce qui va t'arriver
ne rapporte pas d'argent
[Musique]
Rien ne m'est arrivé, Dieu merci.
Bon
[Musique]
si certains montaient
et nous prenons ça
jour
ils ne peuvent pas y arriver
valise avec de la marijuana
parce qu'ils vont te tuer et nous ne le ferons pas
Ils tuent mais si tu n'as pas de chance, ils te tueront
tue là-bas comme si tu n'étais pas de quoi
Presque généralement, ils attrapent du pur
les gens qui ne viennent pas du Mexique
mais tu peux trouver de bonnes personnes non et
aussi
une autre personne Mais s'ils y vont 10 20 c'est
Quand nous sommes arrivés nous nous sommes séparés deux à deux
ou je pars parce que nous sommes nombreux
parce qu'ils vont trouver beaucoup de danger
aller de l'avant est plus dangereux
[Musique]
le problème est là Ce n'est pas là n'est pas
où est il n'y a nulle part
[Musique]
Jackson Nogales
Je suis mexicain mais tu ne connais pas le mien
pays où j'ai passé 25 ans aux Etats-Unis
Les États-Unis m'ont donné l'opportunité
être comme quelqu'un qui vient des États-Unis
ils ont donné l'école, je suis allé au lycée
tout ça
Je suis entré en tant que migrant et je
On leur a donné la possibilité de faire ce qu'ils ont fait.
Malheureusement, je ne savais pas comment en profiter
J'étais jeune et j'avais une mentalité différente
J'y suis allé avec des amis et ils ont fait quelque chose et je
Ils les ont attrapés avec des armes et tout
pour marcher avec eux, j'ai payé dix ans de
prison Et la vérité est que j'ai souffert
faims, humiliations froides dont j'ai souffert
tout
et comme j'étais emprisonné et que je n'étais pas
Sans citoyen, ils m'ont pris mes papiers.
Ils ont été déportés ici
J'ai travaillé mais je suis toujours
avec comme si j'étais seul ici et bien mon
la famille est là mon père ma mère ma
frères, mes frères sont tous là
[Musique]
tout comme au Honduras c'est compliqué
Tu gagnes peu, tu ne donnes que pour rien d'autre
passer par la nourriture quotidienne maintenant pour
le reste et on a des enfants pour l'envoyer
à l'école médicaments vêtements chaussures
tout ça ne donne plus
Parfois, les gens doivent mieux émigrer
pour un autre pays
où sont-ils mais nous sommes arrivés à un endroit
parce que je vois qu'il y a un train ici
la station
mais il n'y a rien, ne quitte pas le patio
plus tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où sommes-nous
on se rapproche
[Musique]
pas seulement
il y a des feux de circulation
non non non ne deviens pas charnel
descendre seulement si un autre train arrive
en passant et quel valp tu peux le télécharger
retour
évidemment mec
rond jusqu'au dos
si tu le sais, prêt
[Musique]
je vais prendre un café
et comment vont-ils faire
ils ne le savent pas encore
puisqu'il faut tout écouter
arrive
voyons avec certitude
Bonjour Sébastien Pérez
Julio m'a invité
Je vous invite à prendre un café et je viens de France
La France jusqu'à présent Alexandre
c'est très important
à l'ouest et traverse le sud, c'est-à-dire
je me lève comme ça et à midi c'est comme ça
côté c'est-à-dire à midi quand le
la chaleur est plus grande, tu dois y aller
le soleil derrière ton ombre doit le faire
être de ce côté
Oui, clair de l'ombre, le soleil derrière le
midi si tu dois le traverser
sensation de ton ombre à midi
Si vous bougez et que l'Ombre regarde dans cette direction, ce n'est pas le cas.
l'ombre est du même côté
[Musique]
salut salut
non non Non Non
non je ne comprends pas ce que tu nous proposes
Qu'est ce que l'on peut faire
il y a des gens qui peuvent s'impliquer
l'autorisation est désormais très restreinte
maintenant ce qu'ils accusent, c'est la mafia
[Musique]
ra
deux mains
je suis l'Amérique
Oui tout va bien
[Musique]
Mon père nous a amenés en bus où nous sommes arrivés
la frontière, nous restons dans l'église
Il pleut quand nous arrivons et il dit
La dame de l'église dit d'attendre
une grosse pluie arrive et ils le retiennent
Les soldats ne seront pas là et il est venu
une eau nous atteignons un point de contrôle et un
soldat, pas un, regarde, nous atteignons l'autre
retenue et ils n'étaient pas comme des yeux de
nous ne sommes même pas arrivés à Los Angeles
La Californie ne ressemble à rien et c'est comme ça
traverser si facilement j'étais petit
cinq ans, cinq ans et demi, c'était le
bon moment
maintenant c'est plus difficile
Qu'en penses-tu ?
de cet endroit, ils peuvent passer ici ou ils s'en vont
pour voir comment je pense d'abord
nous devons chercher parce que je ne connais pas le
la frontière est comme un rêve et bien je ne sais pas quoi
Que va-t-il se passer d’ici à ensuite ?
Il dit certaines choses mais il y a des moments où il ne le fait pas.
ça se passe comme ça alors
passer de mille dollars perdus à mille dollars
des dollars juste pour le laisser là
cinq autres pour les porter
Il existe des modèles aux États-Unis, exemple
qui vous contacte
ils te demandent du travail
exemple à partir de là, ils vous envoient déjà demander
Par exemple, trois hommes du Chiapas
Oaxaca parce qu'il y a des gens très difficiles à
travailler
L'année prochaine, il vous recontactera si
Tout allait bien, je vous recontacterai
Il dit de venir ici et de m'amener un tel et un tel
nous y travaillons à iloy ici
près de l'arizonte
là, ils ont planté de nombreuses pastèques, melon, ail
oignon
regarde jusqu'où ils vont moyen
puis là dans le coin
il décroche, il saute mais il décroche
pur petit coin en ce moment sans caméra c'est parti
va juste voir ici
et passe sous le poing
ici s'ils réussissent s'ils réussissent gratuitement
ici ici et ici ce seront les États
Rejoint
de cet endroit, le tunnel entre
Il arrive ainsi que le moment
ça tourne
Est-ce que cela fait la ligne de démarcation, ok alors
il y a des passages les passages sont exactement faits
tunneler ces passages est vrai, c'est pourquoi et
tu ne sais pas quels billets tu as mais
C'est aussi dangereux pour l'eau bien sûr
une fois que des migrants ont traversé ici
quand ils sont arrivés, il a commencé à pleuvoir
en partie haute l'eau descend puis
Que faisaient-ils, ils ne pouvaient pas revenir
puis nous avons commencé à lui tendre les mains
l'égout et l'aide
Puis les pompiers lui parlent
nous sommes arrivés et peut-être avec une équipe
de la vie nous ouvrons et faisons éclater le
et c'est là que nous avons commencé à les éliminer
[Musique]
le seigneur le seigneur
et ici
Ils arrivent là où toutes les eaux du
ville
l'eau noire semble être là
propre mais pas très contaminé
contaminé Quel produit y a-t-il de tout
et les migrants passent presque en marchant
c'est un gros problème
Combien de kilomètres y a-t-il jusqu'à trois
kilomètres environ aux États-Unis
Unis aux États-Unis, je veux dire oui
l'eau arrive et tu es au fond comme ça plus
vous n'avez aucune marge même s'il y a un
sauf si tu en es proche
d'une bouche d'une prise éventuellement
il n'est plus possible de sortir par un autre chemin
vous sortez
A part ça, l'eau transporte la pierre, elle transporte
les débris charrient quand même et te frappent
et ça provoque ta mort, ça ne te prévient pas
soudainement
et malheureusement les gens qui sont morts
cette année, je n'étais pas de Nogales
Ils venaient de l’extérieur, ils ne connaissaient pas le terrain.
[Musique]
Ça s'appelle comme ça, ok
parce que tu t'es récemment souvenu
du Honduras et dit qu'il est venu dans le
entraîne-toi maintenant ici tu dois aussi dire
Il s'est endormi dans le train et n'est pas descendu d'ici.
ce train est entré et s'est réveillé aux États-Unis
Rejoint
En plus du fait que tu t'es réveillé de façon désagréable
tu t'es reposé
rêve américain
[Musique]
un jour
lentement
[Musique]
nous attendons ici je ne vais pas vérifier je vais le faire
vérifie ça
[Musique]
parce qu'ils vont te tuer
tu dois cacher la voiture
Avec un peu de chance
[Musique]
tueurs à gages
et là il vaut mieux passer la nuit non oui oui
Où est la frontière, elle est à 100 mètres
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il avec
un rôti
[Musique]
je l'utilise de la choline
et si
peut être
[Musique]
nord-est sud-ouest et quand tu lis comme
comme si tu lis les lettres comme comme le
montre neso Autrement dit, si vous ne l'oubliez pas
ce nord-est sud-ouest et de ce côté
Il se couche, donc depuis l'après-midi
tu dois le faire quand le soleil est bon
bien bien bien bien bien dans les montagnes
sur le point de disparaître, juste comme ça, l'ombre
OK, ça ne change jamais, tu dois connaître l'heure
[Musique]
et l'heure l'heure
Pas parce que si tu continues tu fais comme ça si tu continues
l'ombre mais un grand
[Musique]
Ah bonne chance
Puissiez-vous bien faire, Puissiez-vous bien faire
Merci au revoir
[Musique]